welcome back to glamour and filtered
host by meet Josh Smith and today we're
joined by louis Tomlinson how are you
my thanks how are you good so new album
new songs tour on the way you are very
vulnerable in your songwriting and the
music you put out there I'm just honest
yeah what do you think's been the
hardest thing for you to be honest about
with yourself I'm lucky with where a
girl in Doncaster we don't like we wear
our on our sleeves really you know what
I mean so it comes naturally to me
really to kind of just be open about the
way I feel and stuff uh we still live in
a society where it's still seen as bit
of a taboo or there's a stigma around
mentored about vulnerability and that
kind of thing what's that journey been
like for you with that whole stereotype
have you ever felt that level of
stereotype I mean I act like I'm aware
of it but how I operate personally I've
always kind of owned it really you know
I think the mom did a good job of
bringing me up and taught me core values
mr. father when we wrote two of us that
was obviously a very personal song for
me and probably the most vulnerable I've
been especially on a song you know I've
had a couple of moments where fans have
come up to me and told me what that song
means to them and maybe they've just had
a loss in their life and then that's
incredible you not me I never really had
that in the band to that level and you
know my lyrics really mean you some
these people's how difficult has that
been to go through those private things
whilst having this whole massive
microscope on you it was definitely
difficult at first you know when I first
got put in the band and having to deal
with you know not having as much privacy
but I suppose as time goes on you grow
to understand it and and get used to it
and and to be honest you know there has
been some you know pretty hard times in
me life and although I wouldn't have
chosen to have them played out in the
public you know some of the reactions
and some of the stuff I got from fans
was incredible - what would you want to
say to the you that was going through
those deep personal moments are those
times your life what advice would you
want to give that person who can sit
them down now trust yourself and trust
you God because you know those things
are important and nobody
understands you better than you it does
out that I'm able to talk about me
feelings and so far and I can have those
moments where obviously I need to but
yeah it comes naturally to me so I am
I'm lucky I think also as well from
you've had always have this amazing
support network around you throughout
your whole life and I think also when
you're in a band you have four other
members with you as well there's also
that immediate support network because I
was thinking today it must've been so
weird for you to go from having that
immediate support network there all the
time to then it not being there all the
time how difficult was that transition
for you there is still enough familiar
faces to not kind of feel like alienated
and on my own and but it definitely took
some getting used to you know One
Direction was such a well working thing
you know so it definitely took some
getting used to but I think you know as
you spend time on your own you find you
know new people that you really got on
with and develop those relationships how
did you build your identity away from
that part of your life it took me a
second to kind of understand that I was
on my own now and you know my identity
for so long was part of as a collective
and obviously you still have an
individual identity within that so I
think it took me a second to kind of
understand that I can be a bit of a chav
again you know basically and and and
yeah just be me really and not have to
worry too much about anything else did
you ever feel like because he was just
saying about you know he could be a bit
more poor child do you ever feel like
you were having to play anything on me I
think I think sometimes people insinuate
their you know it might be the record
label management oh yeah I like this but
it's not you respectful of the fan base
and their age and we are you know we had
a young fan base and and also they've
got moms who can get angry if you piss
them off you know what I mean so I think
it's just being respectful that I think
so much is made in the media about your
relationships the band and Brotherhood
and all that kind of stuff that we were
just talking about as well have you
leaned into that immediate Brotherhood
you had at times when has it been the
most supportive for you I think that I
think honestly you know there's there's
obviously times where you have better
relationships with all the members than
you do or those but that connection
that'll be forever definitely because
you know we experienced so much in
relatively short space of time and you
know it was it was crazy what we all saw
together an experience so I think that
is something that will have forever and
really definitely sometimes you might
not see eye to eye but but but that's
the way friendships go and real life do
you not I mean
and they also evolve exactly exactly
yeah and people get more mature and all
that yes and you resonate on different
levels and different things I think
that's a positive thing to be able to
take away from definitely definitely how
would you say your relationship with
like Brotherhood and that concept of
Brotherhood has changed through your
career as I've got older really you know
my responsibility is has changed with
with my sisters and me and my little
brother but yeah I think it gets I seem
to understand it more as I get older I'm
currently trying have a conversation
with me twin sisters to go to sick farm
they don't want to go so yeah but I
think I think again you know look I've
just through experience and through
doing it longer and kind of being older
a little bit more mature I suppose
mature I suppose a brother I have to be
I mean yeah we're trying to adult in the
southern respect exactly do you still
have a thing when you're like oh my god
I'm actually adding a while today like
whenever I'm with Mission Freddie and
whenever I'm having like those kind of
conversations about school with the
girls my sisters and that and feel like
then I've got me I don't head on I have
to to have credibility in those
conversations you know me but I
definitely still out like a lot of times
is that anything you would change or if
there's anything you would change how
would you change it every mistake as
Moses you know it's all part your
journey and you do definitely learn
something every time so in terms of my
my career and and and you know I have
come across publicly and all that now I
won't change anything to be honest look
I've got like I'm quite resilient I'm
quite persistent
I was actually the third year that had
auditioned for x-factor and that I got
put in the bands you know I mean so I
I'd say resilience and persistence is
important but obviously you have to have
certain amount of self belief for that
so just to just to be confident really
if you could give someone any advice
because for me you seem like a very
confident person which i think is so
great
letting like a really refreshing nice
way to if people are going through any
sort confidence issues or they've been
through some of the things that you've
been through in your life what kind of
advice would you want to give them find
the people in your life that you know
you love and trust and and talk it
through with people because you know I
might come across as confident and that
but obviously you know you have moments
where you build things up in your head
and you think there and the longer you
live with that thought you know you
think it's you think it's big it ends up
being bigger than the reality of the
situation so I think just as much
communication as possible and and and
yes I'm with you with your family as
well it's so great to see how comforting
you are I love it let me feel good